good morning John in your last video you
were able to quite successfully point
out that I'm a hog and hairy balls were
able to overcome the poor
decision-making skills of their parents
and become successful people despite
their ridiculous names and maybe crispy
bacon would never have become a
successful composer if it weren't for
his ridiculous name but you know it's
good of the job of a parent to help a
child avoid unnecessary anguish and
let's be honest bad man can be a source
of significant anguish so for all of you
future parents and most importantly your
children this is my guide to how to name
your baby properly first say it out loud
say it out loud in every possible
permutation and you might want to run it
by a focus group of 12 year olds like
Andrew peacocks parents never knew and
neither did poor drew until that day in
4th grade this is starting to sound like
a limerick
anyway punchline drew peacock it could
have been avoided with a focus group of
12 year old saying it out loud
second name your child what you will
call your child this has been a problem
for me my entire life I am Hank I have
always been Hank my whole life my
parents called me Hank but they named me
William
so whenever I'm in a doctor's office or
at the airport and somebody asked me
what my name is I said they're thinking
for a second and I feel like a doof
because this person has just asked me
what my name is and I should know what
my name is
and they're hastily adding me to the
suspicious flyer list third if you do
not speak the language where your child
will grow up get some native language
speakers to come in and help you maybe
the world wouldn't really be a better
place if there were fewer hairy dongs
out there but it probably would be a
better place for those hairy dongs
fourth stop trying to be cute I know
your name is Sylva and you think it's
adorable to name your daughter sterling
and your son hi ho and I'm in this group
too my last name is green anything could
be adorable to have a daughter named
olive green but just don't do it because
some day hi-ho silver is going to be an
adolescent and you don't want him to
have another reason to hate you
five check for the top baby names and
avoid them names though you might have
forgotten this in all of the excitement
have a utilitarian purpose they are a
unique identifier that you place upon a
person so that that person can know when
people are talking to or about that
person if your child has the same name
as 10% of the people in their social
group
avenues for you you have failed and
don't just assume that if you avoid John
and Jennifer you're all good let me tell
you those names aren't even in the top
ten anymore the two top baby names of
2010 were Jacob and Isabella and there
were more Jayden's than there were John
six spell like a normal person I don't
understand why parents do this it
doesn't change anything it just means
that in the future you will have to
spell your name every time anyone wants
to write down your name do not name your
child Michael or Kate or Joshua or
Katherine that seventh and last rule
name your child a freaking name do not
name your child after a comic book
character or an item of clothing or a
profession or most importantly do not
name it after some virtue that they will
enjoy all too much rebelling against in
their early teens like chastity okay and
this is the actual final rule there are
no rules let's be honest Harry Baals and
I'm a hog prove that you are not your
name and it doesn't really matter a bad
name really probably won't lead to
anything except a little bit of extra
adolescent angst and let's be honest
adolescents are gonna find their angst
somewhere they might as well find it in
their name John I'll see you tomorrow
endscreen I just got my immunizations
from Haiti but one is Bugs Bunny and the
other is scooby-doo oh I'm going to be
in Haiti and like a week's time which is
good means that I'm going to be in Miami
and less than a week's time so if you've
not bought your tickets you should it's
very possible that we won't have any for
sale at the door so you should
definitely buy in advance